es algo que usted va a presenciar el
capital Hitler la alianza
una de las que es más importantes en el
mundo que es muy cercana muy dinámica
mucho más dinámica que cualquier otro
momento de la historia El Primer
Ministro nos hemos reunido muchas veces
de los últimos años
recientemente en Hiroshima en la Cumbre
del g7 y cada vez me sorprendió nuestra
capacidad de encontrar nuevas áreas de
cooperación juntos estamos desbloqueando
Este futuro compartido de lo que yo creo
que hay un potencial ilimitado con Esta
visita estamos demostrando una vez más
como India y Estados Unidos están
colaborando en casi cada tarea humana y
llevando Progreso a todo el mundo desde
el diseño de nuevas maneras de
diagnosticar enfermedades como cáncer y
diabetes a colaborar en los vuelos
humanos en el espacio incluyendo enviar
un astronauta indio a la estación
2024 acelerar la transición a la energía
limpia a nivel global y enfrentar la
crisis climática que estamos enfrentando
para asumir esta experiencia en
tecnología emergencia y nueva como la
computación cuántica y la Inteligencia
artificial para asegurar
que no sean usadas como herramientas de
desinformación y opresión estamos
duplicando nuestra cooperación para
asegurar
el suministro de semiconductores las
cadenas de suministro en las redes de
telecomunicaciones y también aumentando
esta Alianza con más ejercicios
conjuntos militares más cooperación
entre nuestras industrias de defensa y
más consultas y coordinación en todo
tipo de dominio nuestra relación
económica está aumentando
el comercio se ha duplicado entre estos
países durante la última década
soportando miles de trabajos de alto
pago en India y Estados Unidos junto a
eso un millón de trabajos
estadounidenses en 44 estados serán
respaldados por la compra además de 200
aviones hecho por Estados Unidos por
parte de Air India y eso se anunció
temprano este año con Esta visita India
también está anunciando más de 2.000
millones de dólares en inversiones
nuevas en manufactura en energía solar
en Colorado
acero en Ohio y fibra óptica en Carolina
del Sur mucho más también
mucha más evidencia de que la
manufactura estadounidense está de
vuelta estamos expandiendo intercambio
educativo para nuestros estudiantes
construyendo
creando más de 2500 visas
estadounidenses para que estudiantes
indios vengan a estudiar eso ocurrió el
año pasado y estamos abriendo cada vez
más cámaras y consejos habilitando que
más gente pueda viajar y colaborar
juntos en los temas que más importan que
definirán el futuro de nuestras naciones
se incluyen los temas globales y
regionales hoy también Hablamos
de nuestros esfuerzos compartidos para
mitigar las tragedias humanitarias
liberadas por esta guerra brutal de
Rusia en Ucrania y para defender los
principios núcleo de la carta de las
Naciones Unidas y la integridad
territorial de Ucrania hemos discutido
nuestro trabajo entre Estados Unidos
junto con Australia y Japón para
asegurar
estabilidad para la región ido pacífica
libertad apertura prosperidad y
seguridad
a través de nuestro nuevo programa itu
YouTube con Israel y la Unión Europea
estamos construyendo conexiones con el
medio oriente y creando soluciones para
los desafíos globales como la seguridad
global la seguridad alimentaria y la
energía limpia el liderazgo es
importante también en el g20 y estamos
llevando a cabo estamos poniendo el
desarrollo sostenible al centro de
nuestra agenda
para nuestras naciones
alivia la deuda y construir mucha mayor
resiliencia en estas economías el punto
es simple queremos que todo el mundo
tenga la oportunidad de vivir dignamente
déjeme ser cercano Y cerrar temes que
cerrar esto ahí los indios y los
estadounidenses son pueblos que innovan
que convierten obstáculos en
oportunidades que encuentran fortalezas
en las comunidades y en las familias
apreciamos la libertad
y los Derechos Humanos enfrentamos
desafíos en todo el mundo en cada uno de
nuestros países también
pero lo vital para el éxito de cada una
de nuestras naciones está ahí la
libertad de prensa de la libertad
religiosa la tolerancia y la diversidad
India tiene la mayor población en el
mundo en estos momentos es una
democracia entendemos
que es una nación brillante la
diversidad es
lo que le hace fuerte como nación su
democracia la democracia hace eso vemos
eso con mucha Claridad aquí en Estados
Unidos
donde en una comunidad vibrante
iberoamericana está haciéndose cada vez
más fuerte y contribuye cada día a
escribir el futuro de nuestras naciones
los estadounidenses
representan la diversidad de acá y
persiguen el sueño estadounidense
Mientras más tienen una gran conexión
con las familias indias y con su
tradición eso nos hace cada vez más
fuerte a todos
Ese es el fundamento de esta Alianza
fundamental entre Estados Unidos y por
eso es que sé que la amistad dentro de
nuestras naciones solamente va a seguir
creciendo mientras enfrentamos el futuro
juntos Primer Ministro la palabra es
suya
[Aplausos]
su excelencia presidente
amigos de los medios
primer lugar Le agradezco al presidente
biden por sus cálidos palabras
y por su perspectiva positiva sobre las
relaciones entre India y Estados Unidos
amigos
Hoy es un día
que tiene una importancia especial para
la historia de la relación entre India y
Estados Unidos las discusiones de hoy
las importantes decisiones que se han
tomado
han agregado un nuevo capítulo a esta
relación integral a esta Alianza global
y estratégica le han dado una nueva
dirección y una nueva energía amigos
nuestra Alianza comercial y de
inversiones entre Estados Unidos es muy
importante no solamente para nuestros
dos países
sino para la economía global también
hoy
Estados Unidos
es el mayor Aliado comercial de la India
hemos decidido
resolver
unos inconvenientes comerciales
de larga vida y tomar un nuevo inicio
la iniciativa
para las tecnologías críticas y
emergencias emergentes ha aparecido como
un marco muy importante para nuestra
cooperación técnica
al incrementar nuestra cooperación en
Campos como la Inteligencia artificial
los semiconductores el espacio la
tecnología cuántica y las
telecomunicaciones
estamos creando
una alianza fuerte y futurista
la decisión tomada por las compañías
estadounidenses como Michael Google y
applyte materials
de invertir en India
simboliza
esta Alianza futurista
Durante este viaje
también tuve la oportunidad de conocer a
otros presidentes de compañeros
estadounidenses en mis discusiones con
ellos pude sentir
el entusiasmo y las perspectivas
positivas sobre India estuvimos de
acuerdo
en que para
lograr una alianza tecnológica
estratégica y para hacer que sea
significativa es muy importante
en que los gobiernos que los negocios y
las instituciones académicas se reúnen
con el fin de implementar
la visión compartida de India y Estados
Unidos sobre
la perspectiva de la energía limpia
hemos tomado ciertas iniciativas esto
ocurre áreas como el hidrógeno verde la
energía eólica
el almacenamiento de baterías y la
captura de carbono
también hemos decidido
que en medio de esta incertidumbre
global India y Estados Unidos
como aliados confiables crearán
unas cadenas de suministro globales
resilientes y cadenas de valor también
la cooperación defensiva cercana entre
India y Estados Unidos simboliza
una confianza mutua y unas prioridades
estratégicas compartidas
la anterior relación hemos hecho una
transición
hemos hecho una transición
[Música]
y de las tecnologías espaciales hemos
también establecido una cooperación
importante al asumir esta decisión de
uniros al acuerdo
de aquí en adelante en nuestra
cooperación espacial de hecho
para India y para Estados Unidos para
esta Alianza
el cielo Dejó de ser un límite amigos
el pilar más importante de nuestras
relaciones
es nuestros lazos entre personas
interpersonales más
cuatro millones de personas de origen
indígena
que ellos hagan una gran contribución al
progreso de Estados Unidos de hecho esta
mañana
gran número de indios reunidos en la
casa blanca demostró
que los indios estadounidenses son la
real fortaleza entre nuestras relaciones
con el fin de profundizar estas
relaciones Nosotros le damos la
bienvenida
a la decisión estadounidense de abrir
consulados en bengaluro y en
una manera similar
abriremos unos nuevos consulados de la
India en
amigos en nuestra reunión de hoy
discutimos
varios temas globales regionales
la paz y la seguridad en el lindo
Pacífico es una prioridad común para
nosotros
estamos de acuerdo en que el desarrollo
y el éxito de esta región
es importante para el mundo entero
[Música]
compartimos la perspectiva de mejorar
esta cooperación con todos los países en
la región junto con nuestros aliados
en la lucha contra el terrorismo y
contra el fundamentalismo
Estamos de acuerdo en que la acción
concreta es necesaria con el fin de
acabar el terrorismo que cruza fronteras
la pandemia del covid y el conflicto de
Ucrania han afligido
a los países del sur Global en
particular y nosotros creemos
con el fin de resolver estos problemas
es absolutamente imperativo para todos
los países unirse
desde el inicio de los eventos en
Ucrania India
puesto un gran énfasis en la solución de
esta disputa a través del diálogo y la
diplomacia
estamos completamente listos para
contribuir De cualquier manera posible
a restaurar la paz
bajo la presidencia del g20 de India
hemos puesto énfasis en el espíritu
de una tierra de una familia un futuro
nosotros estamos dándole voz a las
prioridades del sur global
Le agradezco al presidente biden
que haya expresado
respaldo a mi propuesta de darle a la
unión africana
membresía completa del g20 amigos la
filosofía núcleo de todos estos
esfuerzos colectivos es fortalecer la
democracia y los valores democráticos
y el orden democrático
dos de Las mayores democracias del mundo
India y Estados Unidos pueden Unidos
hacer una contribución importante a la
paz global a la estabilidad y a la
prosperidad tengo la confianza
de que basados en estos valores vamos a
poder cumplir las expectativas y las
aspiraciones de no solamente el pueblo
de nuestros dos países sino del mundo
entero presidente Muchas gracias
por esta conversación tan significativa
de hoy
este año durante la Cumbre del g20
tenemos la esperanza de dar la
bienvenida a usted hablo por mí y hablo
por todo India tenemos la expectativa de
darle la bienvenida a la India
como el presidente ha dicho tengo otro
compromiso después de esto tengo que
hablar frente al congreso Entonces no
quiero tomarme mucho más tiempo voy a
detenerme pero de nuevo presidente
Muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
bueno el congreso de hecho está
esperándolo
hay dos preguntas
Sabrina de Wall Street journal
de India Sabrina primero usted por favor
Gracias señor presidente Tengo una
pregunta para el Primer Ministro es una
pregunta de dos partes hay una para
usted sus comentarios en una recaudación
de fondos son los más recientes
en los que un presidente estadounidense
le ha dicho presidente chino dictador
son esos comentarios podrían complicar
El Progreso que su administración
logrado al mantener una relación cochina
en segundo lugar sobre India como usted
habla de estos temas de derechos humanos
y de democracia Cuál es su mensaje a
aquellos incluyendo miembros de su
propio partido que dicen que su
administración está ignorando los
ataques al disenso y a las minorías
religiosas en el país del presidente
móvil su primera pregunta La respuesta
es no
cuando hablamos a nuestros aliados a
nuestros socios en todo el mundo
Incluyendo a la India
les dejamos conocer la idea
de que yo elijo y evito decir lo que
creo que son hechos respecto de la
relación con China
Simplemente no es algo que vaya a
cambiar mucho la verdad creo y lo he
dicho ya en varias ocasiones
y que la histeria sobre la relación de
que china las relaciones está colapsando
etcétera tuvimos un incidente
que causó
cierta confusión podría decirse
pero el secretario blinken tuvo un viaje
muy importante a China Yo espero que se
reúnan con el presidente chi en el
futuro en el corto plazo y no creo que
esto haya tenido ninguna consecuencia
real
su segunda pregunta
A medida usted habla de estos temas de
derechos humanos y democracia Cuál es su
mensaje incluyendo algunos miembros de
su partido
que dicen que su administración está
ignorando el ataque al disenso y a las
minorías En India el primer misterio
Tuvimos una buena discusión sobre los
valores democráticos
y ahí bueno es la naturaleza nuestra
relación somos directos el uno con el
otro nos respetamos también
una de las razones fundamentales por las
que creo que Estados Unidos y China
que esta relación no es tan grave no es
una situación tan grave es que
hay un gran respeto entre China y
nosotros Porque somos democracia
es el carácter democrático de ambos
nuestro carácter el de nuestras personas
nuestra diversidad nuestra cultura
nuestra tolerancia el debate robusto
creo que
la dignidad de Cada ciudadano vale
está en el ADN de Estados Unidos y creo
que también en el de India
todo el mundo tiene que ver con nuestro
éxito y con sostener nuestra democracias
esto nos hace también unos aliados
llamativos y nos permite expandir las
instituciones democráticas en todo el
mundo
yo creo en esto todavía
señor Primer Ministro
India Siente orgullo al ser la mayor
democracia del mundo pero muchos grupos
de Derechos Humanos dicen que ha habido
discriminación desde su gobierno a las
minorías religiosas y que se ha buscado
silenciar a los críticos usted está aquí
en la casa blanca muchos líderes se ha
comprometido a proteger la democracia
qué pasos está dispuesto usted y su
gobierno a tomar para mejorar los
derechos de los musulmanes y otras
minorías en su país y para sostener la
libertad
me sorprende mucho que la gente diga
esto la gente no lo dice India sí es una
democracia
y como también ha mencionado en India y
Estados Unidos
ambos países
la democracia está en nuestro ADN
la democracia está en nuestro es nuestro
espíritu corre por nuestras venas
nosotros vivimos en democracia
y nuestros ancestros
han dado palabras a este concepto es en
la forma de nuestra Constitución
nuestro gobierno
ha tomado los principios básicos de la
democracia
y basado en eso se hace la constitución
el país entero se maneja a través de
nuestra Constitución a través de nuestro
gobierno siempre hemos demostrado que la
democrática la democracia se cumple
Cuando digo que se cumple esto es sin
importar de el Credo del género no hay
ningún espacio para la discriminación y
cuando usted habla de democracia
si acaso
no hay valores humanos y no hay
humanidad
no hay derechos humanos no es una
democracia
por eso es que cuando usted dice
democracia cuando se acepta la
democracia cuando se vive en democracia
no hay ningún espacio para la
discriminación por eso es que India cree
en seguir adelante con todos
[Música]
esto es nuestra base nuestros principios
fundacionales son la base de cómo
operaron de cómo vivimos nuestra vida En
India el beneficio los beneficios
brindados por el gobierno
son accesibles para todos para el que se
merezca esos beneficios están
disponibles para todos
por eso es que los valores democráticos
de India no hay espacio para la
discriminación
ni en casa ni en credo ni en edad ni
ningún tipo de ubicación geográfica